[MUSIC PLAYING]
LOGAN URY: My
name's still Logan.
And I still started this
series a few years ago.
And I write, and
read, and research
dating and relationships.
And it's my pleasure to bring
Eli Finkel here with you
today for this special edition
of Talks at Google Modern
Romance.
So Eli, you thank you
so much for coming.
ELI FINKEL: Thank
you for having me.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
So Eli is a professor
at Northwestern.
And he is the author of a new
book called "The All-or-Nothing
Marriage."
He has appointments in
the psychology department
and the Kellogg
School of Management.
He's the director of
Northwestern's Relationships
and Motivation Lab.
And he has published over
130 scientific articles,
and is a frequent contributor
to "The New York Times."
So everybody, please
welcome Eli Finkel.
ELI FINKEL: Thank you.
LOGAN URY: So for those of
you who are lucky enough
to get one of the
first 15 signed books,
Eli will be signing those
copies for you at the end
if you want to get
them personalized.
And we'll also save 15 minutes
at the end for questions
from the audience.
OK, let's kick it off.
Eli, before we jump
into your new book,
I'd love to ask you about
your research on dating
and attraction.
I'm sure we have quite a few
people in the audience who
are looking for love.
What have you discovered
about online dating?
ELI FINKEL: Oh, we've done
a lot of work on this.
We tried to figure out
the extent to which you
can actually tell from
a profile who's going
to be compatible with you.
We've done a lot of work trying
to investigate whether anybody
has developed an algorithm
that actually works,
that can actually set
you up with somebody
who's compatible with you.
Ultimately, we ended
up being skeptical
about both of those things.
And so we're one of
the few that, I think,
are really enthusiastic
about things like Tinder.
And the reason why is because
online dating is never
going to be able to do
much more for you than
get you a broader pool
of potential partners
and provide the opportunity
to get across a cup of coffee
or a pint of beer.
And that's the way you can
assess whether you're actually
compatible with someone.
LOGAN URY: So based
on your research,
how would you design
the ideal dating app?
ELI FINKEL: I think
I would make it
so that it just didn't
make any claims,
any promises, it didn't
claim, we can find your soul
mate for you.
I mean, this was something that
all the online dating companies
were doing when I first
started looking at this stuff.
We have an algorithm that
can find your soul-mate.
Or come on, and spend 20
hours browsing profiles
to see who is compatible.
And that's why I would be very
minimalist about the thing.
I would just give some sort
of relatively straightforward
interface that people can use.
And I love the idea that you
can add some spontaneity back
into the way you date.
Tinder and its ilk are a little
bit unfortunate in the way
that they prioritize
physical attractiveness.
It's literally like a face that
you swipe left or right on.
So that's a downside.
LOGAN URY: I'm familiar with it.
ELI FINKEL: Yes, you're
familiar with Tinder.
Yes, most of us are,
I think, these days.
But something that's
generally in that space that's
sort of quick, and
dirty, and easy,
and that gets you
face-to-face fast,
that's the optimal online
dating app, I think.
LOGAN URY: Anything about
photos, versus videos,
using pictures that
make you look better
than you do in real life.
ELI FINKEL: Oh, yeah,
you should definitely
use pictures that
make you better
than you do in real
life, highly recommended.
So one of the ideas that
I've been exploring--
but we don't have
the data on yet--
is, is the extent to which
we can make profile browsing
or something like
that approximate
a real-life interaction.
Because to the degree
that you can do that,
to the degree that you can
make the browsing process,
figuring out who's
compatible with you,
approximate what it's
like to be face-to-face
with somebody that you
actually might want to meet,
that might mean you can
bypass the obligation
to meet face-to-face.
Whether there's any
site that can actually
crack this problem,
it's not clear yet.
But I kind of like
the idea that there
might be an algorithm that
somebody could potentially
invent--
I've proposed this idea before--
that would--
LOGAN URY: We are at the
home of algorithms, so.
ELI FINKEL: We are at
the home of algorithms,
for better and for worse.
So there may be a way
that we can leverage
the latest social science
and the latest technology
to develop an
algorithm that's not
going to find your
soul-mate for you,
but that can increase,
by 5% or 10%, the odds
that, when you meet
somebody face-to-face,
you want to go on a second
date with that person.
And I think it resides
at the intersection
of these sorts of non-conscious
behavioral dynamics
that we tend to have in
face-to-face interaction.
For example, when we really
are attracted to somebody,
when we like somebody, we
non-consciously mimic them,
not in a awkward way,
but in a sort of--
not in that sort of way.
And it's possible that we can
capture those sorts of features
and bring them into a potential
matchmaking algorithm.
But we're certainly ahead of
where the industry is now.
LOGAN URY: Great.
So it sounds like,
just to summarize,
something that's
good about Tinder
is that you just have
access to a lot of people
and you can decide quickly.
But maybe if there was
an element of video,
or you could get a sense
for them, or even--
do you know this research from
our friend, Dan Ariely, about--
I think it was MIT
students went on a date
where they both entered
this online digital museum.
And they reacted
to pieces of art.
And that tended to
be a good predictor
for if they liked each other.
ELI FINKEL: Yeah,
I love that work.
So the idea here is that the
problem with profile browsing
and trying to figure out
who's compatible with you
from a computer
screen or an app is
you're able to search
on various qualities,
how tall somebody is, how
old somebody is, maybe
how much money somebody
makes, maybe a body shape.
But really what
matters are things
that you can't search for.
They're things that Dan
Ariely and his colleagues
have called experiential
attributes, things
like rapport, things like
sexual compatibility.
Like, I want to find the
profile that will tell me
whether I'm going to have
unique sexual compatibility
or unique rapport
with an individual.
And so those sorts of
approaches, I think
are intriguing.
To my knowledge, no
mainstream online dating site
has really tried
to leverage them.
LOGAN URY: OK, well, maybe
we'll spark some interest today.
So let's move on to your book,
"The All-or-Nothing Marriage."
What does the title mean?
And why have the stakes for
marriage become all-or-nothing?
ELI FINKEL: "The
All-or-Nothing Marriage"
isn't about one
marriage, in particular.
It's about the era of marriage
that we're in right now.
The idea is that we have arrived
at a period in marriage--
particularly, marriage
in America, so 2017--
where the best marriages are
better than the best marriages
of earlier eras, while
at the same time,
the average marriage is
getting a little bit worse.
And so this is the idea
of the all marriage,
those particularly strong
marriages, stronger than,
really, what we had seen in
any other era that I know of.
So we have those particularly
strong marriages.
And at the same time, the
average marriage is struggling.
So that's the idea of the
all or the nothing marriage.
LOGAN URY: Great.
And at one point, you
write that "marriage
has gone from till death
do us part to today's
till death do us part or
we become unfulfilled."
Are our expectations
for marriage too high?
And are we bound for failure?
ELI FINKEL: I am delighted
that you asked me this.
So this is a big topic.
And there's no
shortage of people
willing to chime
in on the question
of whether our
expectations for marriage
are too high, whether we
should, in fact, lower them.
My perspective on this
is that you can't answer
that question in isolation.
The right question is
not, are your expectations
too high or too low?
But are your
expectations calibrated
for what the marriage
realistically can provide?
And so I don't have this, I
think, skeptical or cynical
view that says we're
asking too much.
Because it's primarily
because of how much
we're asking of
our marriage that
makes having a pretty
spectacular marriage something
that's within reach
today to a degree
that it would have been
out of reach in the past.
And so these expectations
can be great.
The problem is, when you have
these sorts of expectations,
you might end up
in a marriage that
would have been totally
fulfilling for you in 1950
and falls short now.
And you end up disappointed.
So again, the idea isn't
about whether the expectations
are high or low.
The idea is whether
the expectations
are appropriately
tailored in light
of what I'm like, what
you're like, the dynamics
that the two of
us have together.
And those of us who have high
expectations and the marriage
fulfills those expectations,
it's pretty great.
LOGAN URY: So speaking
of changing expectations,
one of my favorite
concepts from your book
is the concept of the
Michelangelo effect.
Will you explain what it is
and how it effects are changing
expectations of marriage?
ELI FINKEL: I do love this one.
So my doctoral mentor, a
woman named Caryl Rusbult,
a social psychologist, she
developed this metaphor
for thinking about how
relationships work.
And she borrowed an
idea from Michelangelo,
the famous Renaissance sculptor.
And he talked about
sculpting-- and some of you
might know this
already-- he talked
about sculpting not as a
process of creating a sculpture,
but as a process of
revealing a sculpture.
And this is, obviously,
profoundly modest.
But in a real sense, it's true.
There was some massive
piece of marble.
And he chiseled.
And he scraped.
Any buffed until
there was a David.
And the idea is
all of us have what
you might call the actual
self, the person we are today.
But all of us also
have an ideal self.
There's a better version
of us nested within us.
There's an aspirational
version, who's
better about being disciplined
in goal pursuit, who
is kinder to other people,
who is more patient,
whatever it is.
It's going to vary from
one of us to the next.
But the idea is that, yes, we
pursue these goals as if we
are sole, independent agents.
But the extent to which we're
able to achieve our life goals,
the extent to which we're able
to grow from our actual self
to our ideal self, is
influenced profoundly
by the nature of our
social relationships.
And at least in
contemporary America,
there is no relationship
that affects this
anywhere near as much, on
average, as the marriage does.
And so one of the ideas
I play with in the book
is, all right, so we're
responsible these days
for sculpting each
other in a way that
helps to bring out the
best in each other,
and in particular,
to help us align
our actual self
with our ideal self,
with our aspirational,
authentic sense of self.
And this is a big, extra
ask for the marriage
that people didn't used to ask.
But like I said, asking
for those high-level things
can have some benefits too.
LOGAN URY: So what's
an example of somebody
wanting the Michelangelo effect
to happen in their marriage?
ELI FINKEL: OK, so you are
somebody who has always dreamed
of being an entrepreneur.
I could have given
a different example
if I weren't talking
to a Google audience.
But let's use this example.
So you've always dreamed
of being an entrepreneur.
But the fact is, it's scary.
It's scary.
It's much easier to
have a stable salary
and not be
responsible for making
the entire business succeed.
And so there you are.
And you've reached
a certain age.
And maybe the kids are
getting a little bit older.
And you haven't really
taken this risk yet.
Now that's the thing about
the actual and the ideal self.
Those goals that we have that
are part of our ideal self
but not part of our
actual self are hard.
If they were easy, we would
have achieved them by now.
And so our partner,
today, to the degree
that we have these sorts of
expectations of our marriage
that are much more common
today than in the past,
our partner has some
sense of responsibility,
some sense of obligation
to push us to achieve
these sorts of ambitious,
risky, difficult sorts of goals
that we haven't
achieved thus far.
And, oh, by the way,
while our partner
is pushing us toward this
greater level of excellence,
this greater level of
personal fulfillment,
of aspirational
fulfillment, she's
also responsible for helping
us feel safe, and loved,
and nurtured and competent.
So how do you do that?
How do you make your spouse
feel simultaneously ambitious,
and hungry, and focused on the
discrepancies between who they
are and who they
could be, and also
make us feel loved,
and competent and safe?
This is a difficult
thing to make somebody
feel simultaneously
happy with themselves
and hungry to change.
LOGAN URY: This sounds risky.
Because in that
example you gave,
if the person ends up not
becoming an entrepreneur--
maybe it just wasn't in them--
they might blame their
spouse for, oh, you
didn't encourage me enough.
Or you put too much
responsibility on me,
and I couldn't take a risk.
So what ends up happening?
ELI FINKEL: I mean, I
do think it's risky.
I really do.
Does anybody know
somebody who has
been in a warm, loving
relationship that's generally
functioning pretty well?
Co-CEOs of the
household is going fine
and respect for each
other is going fine.
And yet, they think,
I'm not growing.
I'm stagnant.
Like, that would have been
a great marriage in 1950--
or at least it could have been
a very sensible, satisfying
marriage in 1950.
But these days,
more and more of us
feel like that's
not enough anymore.
And yes, we have to
take some responsibility
for the extent to which we're
achieving our own goals.
But there is this implicit
assumption these days
that, if I'm not growing, one of
the reasons why I'm not growing
is because the marriage itself
isn't doing with the marriage
itself is supposed to do.
And we do end up disappointed
with a marriage that,
a couple of
generations ago, would
have been fulfilling for us.
LOGAN URY: So would you say to
that person, just because you
didn't become a
entrepreneur, don't break up
your marriage over that.
Lower your expectations.
ELI FINKEL: Oh, boy, it's
hard to get prescriptive,
in a general sense.
So I actually feel like, if
I had a very concrete case
in front of me,
maybe I would feel--
LOGAN URY: We'll
see if anyone wants
to volunteer their marriage.
Yes Yes.
Anybody here, like, profoundly
disappointed in your marriage
and want to share with
the general public?
No, probably not, on average.
I would say that
there are many ways
to build a successful
marriage, and that there
are no rules that say that we
have to ask our spouse for all
of these things.
And we, ourselves,
need to be taking
a fair bit of responsibility
for places where we're growing,
or not growing, feeling
stagnant, versus thriving.
And we have broad
social networks.
So I mean, Esther
Perel has talked
about how we look
to our partner to do
what a village used to do.
And it's basically true.
The amount that we expect our
spouse to do for us these days
is extraordinarily
high by comparison
to 50 years ago, but
certainly 200 years
ago. particularly with regard
to our emotional or deeper sort
of psychological needs.
And so I feel like, man,
we have a lot of friends.
We have a lot of other
significant others in our life
other than our spouse.
And there probably
are successful ways
of dealing with
the situation that
don't call for terminating a
relationship that's otherwise
fulfilling.
LOGAN URY: OK, so it
sounds like the answer
isn't necessarily higher
or lower expectations.
It's looking for
support elsewhere.
ELI FINKEL: Yes it's
calibrating expectations
to what's realistic,
and then building a life
that is successful or
that has the potential
to be successful in helping us
meet our broad sense of goals
and responsibilities.
And these days, a
lot of us actually
really do take
pride in our ability
to build and sustain
a self-expressive sort
of marriage.
I mean, for a long time,
people were very concerned--
I think, rightfully so--
that if marriage was
now going to focus
on personal fulfillment, which
really didn't start until about
the 1800s, if
marriage-- we're now
going to focus on
personal fulfillment.
Why would anybody ever be
committed to their marriage?
Like, aren't these
incompatible ideals?
One of the ideas I
play with in the book
is that personal fulfillment has
a bunch of different flavors.
And two of the most
significant flavors
are the distinction
between, like, happiness
that is a pleasure-based
system versus a meaning
or purpose-based system.
And a lot of us who are
trying to achieve fulfillment
in a meaning-based,
a purpose-based way
find that an effective
means of doing
that-- a particularly
effective means of doing that--
is building, and
developing and maintaining
a marriage over time,
even when it's hard.
Building a marriage and
sustaining it even when
it's hard is one of the ways
that we can grow and one
of the ways that we
can actually achieve
this type of fulfillment
that a lot of us
are pursuing these days.
LOGAN URY: So you
mentioned recalibrating.
And one of the
parts of your book
that I found really
interesting is
when you talked about, after
the birth of your first child,
you're experiencing
some postpartum.
And you actually asked
for different things
from the marriage.
Can you talk a little bit
about that experience?
ELI FINKEL: Yeah, I
mean, I'm happy to talk
about my personal experience
with this, in large part
because I'm sure that we're
not the only couple that
went through this.
And there's some stigma
associated with this stuff.
So I went into something
approximating a postpartum
depression.
I don't think I technically
had a diagnosis.
But it was really hard.
And we have something of
an ideology of parenthood,
that it's acceptable to
say that you got depressed
after the kid arrived if
you had a hormonal crash.
But it's not really considered
acceptable to say that if you
didn't have a hormonal crash.
But if you read the evidence,
something like 25% of men
will go through
at least a period
where they have this stuff.
It's of course,
harder for women,
even if you were to
subtract out the hormones.
It's, an average, harder
for women these days.
And so the question is--
there you are.
You exist today.
Most of us have this
perspective on what
marriage should do for us and
how marriage should function.
And by and large, in those first
couple of years of marriage,
many of us are able to
achieve all of that stuff.
These emotional,
psychological needs
help with personal growth--
loving, sexy type relationship.
And then the kid comes.
And look, some of us
will just get closer.
And the sex will get hotter.
And we'll manage to have just
as much time together as before.
But those of us
are the exceptions.
The rule is that you will
have less time together
with your spouse, less sex than
you did in the past, more puke
than you did before.
And in general, it's a
pretty difficult time.
And that the evidence
on this stuff
is now very clear, that it is
a perilous time for a marriage,
the arrival of the first kid.
None of this is to say that you
don't love your kid like crazy
and that, when your
kid's four and five,
you don't miss kissing
that fuzzy little head.
I do.
I miss it all the time.
You know, The newborn phase is
appealing in all sorts of ways.
The problem is, if you haven't
calibrated your expectations
about the marriage to be
realistic in light of what
your life is going to be like
for some number of months
or maybe years, you're going
to end up disappointed.
And I did.
And Allison did.
My wife did.
We ended up really
struggling, I mean, really
struggling for
maybe a year or two.
And then when she proposed that
we should have a second kid,
I was like, are
you joking with me?
But when I say she proposed, I
mean she just informed, really.
It was more just like, we're
going to have a second one.
And I said, OK.
That sounds fine.
But what we did
effectively-- and I
don't remember us being
that strategic about it.
But I think it was the most
important thing we've ever
done in our marriage--
is we recalibrated
our expectations to say, it's
going to be a rough stretch.
And let's stop expecting to
have as much time together,
as much intimate
experience together,
really expecting to enjoy
each other as much as usual,
at least for a little while,
at least till we're sleeping
through the night, for example.
And the second time around was,
really, a lot easier for us.
And I think we were able to
use something-- in the book,
I talk about some things
called love hacks.
I don't know if we'll
talk about that here.
But there's some
quick and dirty things
you can do in your
marriage, even when
you don't have time to do
these full-on investments
that relationships experts
are always telling you,
you have to do, how you're using
your date nights, and so forth.
The quick and dirty
things we can do--
Allison and I did some of those.
And I think it really
got us to the point
where we had time
together again.
And we could really
work on having
a particularly strong marriage
again some years later.
LOGAN URY: Great.
Yeah, we'll come
back to love hacks.
ELI FINKEL: Sure.
LOGAN URY: But I'm
B we've gone down
this tangent about expectations.
Because a few weeks ago, we
had Mandy Len Catron here.
And she was here
about her book "How
to Fall in love With Anyone."
And the whole book is about
the danger of love stories.
And in your book, you
talk about how people
who have really high
expectations of relationships,
in some ways, it's good.
They can bring out the
best in their partner.
But when they hit
trouble, they're
actually not well-suited
to handle those struggles.
Perhaps, you could talk
a little bit about that.
ELI FINKEL: Yeah, I mean
this is, in some sense,
the thesis of the book.
The thesis of my
book is basically
that the changing nature
of our expectations
has put these great
marriages within reach.
But it makes it more
difficult to achieve them.
And so with regard
to this idea that we
have these scripts,
these stories,
these expectations about how the
relationship is supposed to go,
we now have set up a
very specific benchmark.
And it's pretty clear
when we're falling
short of that benchmark.
And actually, some of my
favorite recent research
in social psychology is
by a researcher named
Lisa Neff, who is at UT Austin.
And she's shown that, with
regard to the question,
is it good or bad to have
high or low expectations
in your marriage, she has
an interesting perspective
on this, which is, it's good to
have high global expectations,
like, my husband is a good guy.
But it's dangerous to have
high specific expectations,
like, my husband and I will
have sex at least once a week.
And the idea is that you can't
really falsify the good guy
story very easily.
There's always some way
you can interpret things
as an exception or whatever.
But the very concrete
expectations, like,
I'm looking concretely to
have these sorts of things
in the marriage.
And that's what the definition
of a good marriage is.
When we fall short of those
specific, concrete sorts
of expectations,
that's the case where
having those high expectations
is particularly costly.
LOGAN URY: Great.
So we've talked a
lot about marriage.
But there's many happy couples
that live together and are not
married.
So you, the relationship
expert, describe
yourself as pro-marriage.
What is so special
about marriage?
ELI FINKEL: Well, marriage--
so let me say two
things about this.
I am not of the view that
everybody must marry.
I mean, I am
pro-marriage, in the sense
that there are various ways
that we can live our lives.
And getting married to
somebody we're compatible with
and then building a long-term
relationship with that person
looks like it is
a very good one.
That is, if you look
at the evidence,
in terms of
relationship well-being,
but also personal
well-being, this
is a life choice that
tends to be beneficial.
Now of course, there's no
guarantee that getting married
will get you into one of
these good relationships.
So many people are obviously
happier being single.
And that's a good
lifestyle choice too.
"The All-or-Nothing
Marriage" book
is a blend of an investigation
of marriage as an institution.
I was really interested in how
our expectations of marriage,
per se-- not of relationships,
but of marriage, per se--
have changed, and the
way that has changed
how we relate in marriage,
and whether we're
happy in the
marriage versus not.
I think it's great that we
now have a more flexible
institution of marriage.
It used to be a very
exclusive, rigid, strict way
of thinking about marriage.
These days, especially with the
Supreme Court decision in 2015,
for example, that the gay
marriage is now legal--
so I think there's no
reason why somebody
who doesn't want to get
married should get married.
But I will say that,
those of us who
marry and are happy in
that marriage, the research
is clear that those
people tend to have very
fulfilling lives, in general.
And also, it seems to be, among
other options, a good option
for raising a family.
LOGAN URY: So speaking
of the research
on who tends to get married,
someone without a high school
degree is much
less likely to have
a successful marriage
than someone who
graduated from college.
So is marriage
becoming an institution
for the wealthy
and well-educated?
ELI FINKEL: Well, to
some degree it has.
But I don't think
that's good news.
So evidence that I
review in the book
shows that marriage rates are
significantly down among people
without a high school
education in America.
Among those who do marry,
divorce rates are quite high.
In contrast, among people with
at least a college degree,
divorce rates have been
plummeting since 1980.
They're down significantly.
The institution is
doing pretty well
among people with
a college degree.
So it is, in a
sense, an institution
that's working for people with
more education and more income,
for example, rather than
for people with less
education and less income.
But there's no
evidence that people
who have less education
and less income
have really disengaged
from a desire to marry.
That was a reasonable hypothesis
when you looked at the data.
It's like, oh,
well, maybe people
who don't have a
high school degree
think marriage is
silly or passe.
If anything, that was supposed
to be the educated among us who
were supposed to do that.
But of course, we became
quite traditional, actually,
in our personal lifestyles.
So the respect for the
institution of marriage
is very high among
that group of people
whose marriage is struggling.
You can also look
at the evidence.
Maybe they have different
instincts, different intuitions
about what makes for a happier
versus a less happy marriage?
No.
By and large, there
are no differences
in what people think is
important in a marriage.
And I think the story
that we're getting here
is, it's reasonable
to expect our marriage
to try to do these high-level
psychological needs to meet
these expectations that we have.
But it's hard to do it when
we are under duress, when
we are under stress,
when our circumstances
are so challenging that we
don't have time-- even when
we do get time alone
together, we have to talk
about heavy, weighty stuff.
Or we have to fight about
where the money is coming from,
for example.
So for me, the analogy to
what Allison and I confronted
when we endured the
difficult time after when
I went through my
postpartum depression,
for example, the difficult time
after having our first kid,
I think has
interesting analogies
to what it's like to
try to live in the sort
of self-expressive
era of marriage
when you're trying to hold
down two or three jobs, each
of which requires a commute
on two or three buses.
It's just there's more
stress in those marriages.
And it's more difficult,
even with the time
you get, to let go of the stress
and really savor each other.
So I think it's
difficult for people
who have that high
a level of stress
in their life to succeed
with the current expectations
that most of us have.
LOGAN URY: So it sounds
like all groups of people
tend to want the same thing.
But it's harder to get
that all marriage when
you are under a lot of stress
and you have distractions.
ELI FINKEL: Yes.
Another reasonable
hypothesis might have been--
Eli, that's ridiculous.
You're saying that people
without a high school degree,
that they also want love
and even self-expression.
Like, that seems silly.
But the evidence that
exists is clear with this.
So for example, if you
ask people, including
a large sample of
people on welfare,
nationally-representative
samples of people
who are poor to well-to-do,
and everything in between,
and you ask them how important
these various things are
in your marriage, including,
like, my partner supports
my hopes and dreams,
there is no difference.
Up and down the
socioeconomic hierarchy,
there is no difference
in the extent
to which people want that.
And sometimes, when I
get the criticism that
says that I'm sort
of being insensitive,
life is really
hard at the bottom
of the socioeconomic
ladder, I sort of
feel like those people
are being insulting.
Like, really, you
don't think poor people
want a marriage that supports
their hopes and dreams?
Of course, they do.
The problem is, it's really
hard to succeed in a marriage
that you're looking for to
do those sorts of things
when the stress
level is so high,
when the exhaustion from dealing
with your day-to-day life
is so high.
LOGAN URY: Yeah,
that's fascinating.
I guess, if we wanted
to support marriage
in those areas of
the country, it
would actually be about
things like providing
affordable childcare.
ELI FINKEL: Yes.
I mean, I try in the book not
to get particularly political.
But I don't think there's
much avoiding the conclusion
that probably the best
way to help the poor
have more successful
marriages is
through liberal-leaning
social policies, more generous
child care across the board.
We tend to be relatively
conservative on these--
compared, certainly, to Western
nations, but even by comparison
to pretty much
anywhere in the world
about, for example,
the requirement
to have paid child care leave.
So I don't think
that we're going
to be able to fix marriage
in America among, say,
the poor and relatively
uneducated by teaching them
relationship skills.
I think we can maybe help
around the edges with that.
But I think, until we
make day-to-day life
more tenable, more feasible,
more livable for the poor,
it's going to be
very hard for them
to have successful marriages.
Just like it would
be very hard for us
to have successful marriages
if we were in their situation.
LOGAN URY: It's interesting
that you mention our child care
policy versus in
other countries.
Because in the book, you
talk about, specifically,
marriage in America.
And you mentioned that people
here tend to marry and divorce
at elevated rates.
What are some other ways
in which American marriages
are distinct?
ELI FINKEL: So this marrying
and divorcing at elevated rates
is interesting.
Because it results from
certain cultural tendencies
that we have that people,
even in other Western nations,
don't tend to have.
Here, I'm referencing
some research
by the sociologist Andy
Cherlin at Johns Hopkins.
So there are lots of
Western nations that
place a great emphasis
on individuality
and self-expression,
so for example,
the Scandinavian countries
or Holland, for example.
There are also lots of
countries, Western nations,
that place a lot of
emphasis on the importance
of marital commitment, for
example, Greece, Italy.
But according to Andy Cherlin--
and I think his evidence here
is good--
we're unique among
Western nations.
That is, we, in America, are
unique among Western nations
in the extent to
which we prioritize
both of those things.
And his 2009 book is called
"The Marriage Go Round."
And the reason why
it's called that
is because we have this huge
respect for the institution
of marriage.
So we get married.
But then we have this
really strong emphasis
that I shouldn't have
to make sacrifices,
that my self-expression and
personal growth is crucial.
And I shouldn't have to make
sacrifices in the relationship.
So we divorce.
But then we have
this great respect
for the institution of marriage.
So we remarry.
And this process continues.
And I think he's right.
Whether we can actually fix
that, whether we can actually
develop a version of the
sort of self-emphasis,
the individuality emphasis, that
can obviate the need to divorce
when things become sort of
restricting and so forth,
I think we can do that.
And I think we now are
starting to see pioneers,
these people who are really
flourishing in the current era,
who, yes, they do
value self-expression.
They value the importance
of feeling free and feeling
like they can grow
through the marriage.
But they're able to
do it in such a way
that they still appreciate
marital commitment.
And then they can
help each other grow.
And those are the marriages
that, hopefully, we're
starting to see now.
And hopefully, this will
be the new marital system
that we have in
the coming decades.
LOGAN URY: So what's the
impact of a happy marriage
on our overall
life satisfaction?
ELI FINKEL: Huge, huge.
I mean, the evidence that
exists, that correlates,
how happy are you with
some domain in your life,
and how happy are you overall
with your quality of life,
in general?
The quality of your
marriage-- among people
who are married-- the
quality of your marriage
is the single largest predictor
of your overall quality of life
above, how happy are
you with your health?
How happy are you with your job?
So getting this one right
is a really big deal.
It's probably, again, among
people who are going to marry,
it is probably the
biggest decision
that you'll make in your life.
And once you've made the
decision-- actually, sorry.
Having kids is a
bigger decision.
But it is one of the
biggest decisions
that you will make in your life.
And then once you've
made the decision,
working to cultivate
a relationship that's
really fulfilling for
the two of us is--
I mean, I don't know that there
are better uses of your time
and other resources
than trying to cultivate
a strong relationship
in that way.
LOGAN URY: So knowing
the large impact
that marital satisfaction
has on overall happiness,
I can't be the
only one who feels
nervous about achieving that.
ELI FINKEL: Don't mess up.
Please, whatever you
do, don't mess up.
LOGAN URY: So for
those of us who
aren't married, what are the
most important factors we
should consider when
choosing a partner?
ELI FINKEL: You know,
this is one that, again,
it's hard to have
one-size-fits-all answers.
But one of the
things that I think
is pretty low-hanging
fruit that very few of us
do as actively as we could is
to do our best to forecast out
a little bit.
So people make decisions
based on how much we're
in love with each other,
like how much we enjoy
each other's company,
and how much we're
in love with each other.
We take this
snapshot of moments,
snapshot of two years
when we're in our--
I don't know-- late 20s,
and then say, this is it.
This is the one.
I'm going to do this forever.
But how representative
of your life together
is that snapshot of two years?
Probably very little,
especially for people
who plan to have kids.
And so, as much as possible,
we can make an effort
to forecast out a little
bit, to say, well, where
do I want to be in 10 years?
Where do you want
to be in 10 years?
And really try to
listen to those things.
And try to be honest with
yourself and with each other
about those things.
Because it can happen
that the version of you
that you love the most,
the version of you
that you're trying to
achieve, this ideal self,
that David nested within you
that you're trying to achieve,
isn't the version of you
that your partner really
loves most about you.
We have multiple,
complex selves.
And getting some sense
of where I hope to be,
where you hope to
be is a big deal.
And then in a more
pragmatic level,
how do we think we want to
navigate things like careers
when the children come?
It turns out that, except
for the extremely wealthy,
it's pretty hard for
both people to keep
going gonzo on the career
front when the kid comes.
So who is going to
make those sacrifices?
And how are you going to
navigate those things?
So I think these are
questions that we can ask.
The issue is, even if
you ask those questions,
and even if you think
effectively about the answers
to those questions, you
still really don't know.
It's helpful to do,
rather than not do.
Because your ability to forecast
into the future is not zero.
But it's hard to know
how you're going to feel.
Like, I promise
you that I'm going
to be the one who is the primary
caregiver until the kids are
in kindergarten.
You might say that, and mean
it in the most fervent way
from the bottom of your heart,
and then feel distraught,
feel this great sense
of loss and isolation
that you're doing that
task-- or maybe the opposite,
that I'm willing to commit to
be the primary breadwinner.
But then you just
feel heartache all day
because you want to
be with your kids.
So do it.
Have these discussions.
But the truth is, marriage is
always going to be a gamble.
And I think that's, like, the
most beautiful thing about it.
It's this flying leap that
says, you're going to change.
I'm going to change.
We're compatible at the moment.
And we're just going
to do the best we can.
so that, even though
you're changing,
and even though
I'm changing, we're
going to do everything
possible to make sure
that we stay compatible over
the next coming decades.
LOGAN URY: I love that framing.
Instead of seeing
it as terrifying,
it's a beautiful flying leap.
ELI FINKEL: It's beautiful.
It really is beautiful.
I mean, think of the things
that we do that are beautiful.
In your entire life,
you're not going
to do many things more beautiful
than saying, I love you
and I want to make
a life with you.
And let me just say, to hearken
back to your previous point,
this doesn't have to be
an official marriage.
And there's many other things
that we do that are beautiful.
But one of the things that
we do that is very beautiful
is to say, obviously, we
can't predict the future.
And yet, here I am.
LOGAN URY: I guess the
all-or-nothing long-term
relationship didn't have
the same ring to it.
ELI FINKEL: No, the
all-or-nothing long-term
relationship did not
have quite as panache.
LOGAN URY: Yeah.
But I love this advice,
because I recently
interviewed a divorce lawyer.
And I was asking him,
what are the reasons
that people get divorced
that I wouldn't necessarily
know about?
And he said, people
tend to focus
on the wedding, this big day.
And he said, the wedding is
just one day in your marriage.
And he said, you
wouldn't believe
how many couples come to me.
They haven't talked about
where they want to live.
who's going to work or not,
if they want to have kids.
So it's kind of exactly
what you're saying.
ELI FINKEL: I mean, blame
Walt Disney for this.
I mean, whoever invented the
phrase or the end of sentence,
and they all lived happily
ever, after was, like, really
kind of a jerk.
Because we're led to believe
from mainstream cinema
and other sorts of
stories that, really, it's
about the process of, like,
working through complexities
and finally finding each other.
And then that's it.
And then they all live
happily ever after.
From the perspective of a
relationship researcher,
that is, like, certifiable.
The idea that, on
your wedding day--
or you finally have the
fancy kiss in the rain.
And it's like, you just
got through the easy part.
Don't tell me that
that's the hard part
and now everything's
going to be fine.
And I think that's the
same idea that the divorce
lawyer that you're
mentioning talks about
is, it is going to be hard.
I don't want to be overly
cynical about this stuff.
But there's no way
that you're going
to have 50 years of
unadulterated bliss
with your spouse.
And some sort of
sober open-mindedness
about the ways that
we can navigate
those sorts of conflicts--
for example, one of the ideas
that I think is fun is,
we can change how we think
about conflict in the marriage.
We can think about
conflict as something
that reveals incompatibility.
Or we can think about
conflict as an opportunity
to grow, and develop and learn.
And these are the
sorts of things
that, if you have this
heavily romanticized view,
you're probably going to
get that one wrong and maybe
wrong in a profound way.
LOGAN URY: Now's the
perfect time to transition
into talking about love
hacks or the techniques
that couples can use to
improve their relationships.
Why don't you tell us about
a few of your favorites
that you mentioned in the book?
ELI FINKEL: I will do that.
So the context for this is, we
talked a little bit about how
the rising expectations
means that particularly great
marital fulfillment
is within reach.
But the average marriage
is getting a little worse.
To some degree, this is
all a big, gussied up
supply and demand perspective.
It says, well, what should
you ask of your marriage?
What should you demand
of your marriage?
Well, it depends on how much
the marriage is able to supply.
How compatible are you?
How much time are you
spending together?
How are you using
that time together?
How good are you
at communicating?
And you need to make
sure that you're not
asking more than the
marriage can provide,
or you will end up disappointed.
And so we can talk about
three general strategies
for making the marriage better.
One is going all-in strategies,
that relationships people
will always tell you about.
I'd be happy to talk
to you about that.
We talked a little bit
about lowering expectations.
But what if you're in
this period where you say,
I'm not ready to give
up on the all marriage?
I'm not ready to give up
on those expectations,
these really high-level
psychological
and emotional expectations
I have for the marriage.
But holy hell, there are two
screaming toddlers at home.
And there's a
slow-burning work crisis.
There's no way that I'm going
to find extra time to have
to have intimate time
together or a particularly
thrilling, scintillating
date night once a week.
It's just not the time for that.
So this is where I think love
hacks, this set of procedures
I've introduced in the book, I
think are particularly helpful.
I talk about eight.
All of them are
based in science.
So these are all
research-supported procedures
that social scientists have
developed in the last 10, 15
years or so that we can use.
So one of my favorites--
I am biased.
We developed this
one in our lab.
But it involves how we
think about conflict.
So I'll tell you about that.
The two defining
features of a love hack--
I forgot to mention
this earlier.
Number one, these are
quick and dirty things.
So maybe-- I don't know--
10 minutes a month.
Number two, you don't even have
to do them with your partner.
So these are things
that you can do that--
according to Marcel
Proust, mystery
is not about traveling
to new places,
but about looking with new eyes.
So love hacks are things we can
do to try to look with new eyes
at the relationship, look
with the generous new eyes.
So this procedure from
our lab, what happens
is this is a way that we can
think more constructively
about conflict in the marriage.
And so what we did
in this study is we
brought in 120 married couples.
And every four
months for two years,
they wrote about
the biggest conflict
they had in their marriage.
In the second year, we randomly
assigned half of those people--
yes, also to write
about the conflict,
but to do seven additional
minutes of writing, trying
to think about the conflict
from the perspective
of a neutral third
party who wants
the best for all involved.
So again, you've got
the control condition.
Then you've got
this extra condition
where, for seven
minutes, you're trying
to think about the conflict,
not from your own perspective,
but from the perspective of a
neutral third party who wants
the best for all involved.
And we find that
doing that procedure
does, indeed, increase
marital satisfaction, even
marital passion,
which surprised us.
And there are a number
of other techniques
I talk about in the book,
particularly the extent
to which we have some
control over how we
explain our partner's behavior.
Like, we think we're
affected directly
by our partner's behavior.
But by and large, that's false.
We're affected by
our perceptions
of our partner's behavior.
And so we have a
good deal of control
if we want to exert it about
how we feel about it when
our partner doesn't
call us back,
how we feel about it when our
partner gives us a surprise
gift.
And the book talks
a lot about how
we can leverage these
insights about the way we
think about the marriage
to strengthen the marriage.
LOGAN URY: So to
summarize, there
is the going all-in
strategies, which
are what probably many of
us have heard about, like,
spend more time together.
Have more sex.
Go on date nights.
There's the love hacks,
which are quick and dirty.
And then, I think,
this was the first book
that I really read that talked
about these recalibrations.
And one of them
was that couples--
and you mentioned, this
is very high-risk-- might
want to consider opening
up their marriages.
So can you tell us
a bit about what
the research says about how
consensual, non-monogamous
relationships work?
ELI FINKEL: Sure.
Millennials, stay tuned in.
Gen Xers, it's a
little dicey here.
And other generations,
please tune out.
Look, I spend a whole
chapter in the book that
talks about a variety
of ways that we
can ask less of the marriage.
There's a whole chapter on this.
There's chapters on love hacks.
There's a chapter on how we
can go all-in, the best way
to use our date night time.
Like, just saying, go on date
nights is not sufficient,
but research now tells
us, what are good ways
to use that time together?
And I have a chapter
saying, look,
there are probably ways that
your marriage is reliably
falling short of expectations.
And it's making you frustrated.
And it's making you angry.
And it's making
you disappointed.
Can you identify
what those areas are?
And if you can't fix them
through going all-in,
there's no reason
why you have to ask
that stuff of the marriage.
There might be ways
that you can reduce
the amount of
disappointment that you feel
by asking less of the marriage.
And again, there's a number
of procedures I talk about.
But yes, one of the
ones that I talk about
is consensual non-monogamy.
Now again, this is not cheating.
This is consensual non-monogamy.
There's a bunch of
variations on these ideas.
I think there's a
lot of people who
can enjoy consensual
non-monogamy
for a lot of reasons.
But one of the reasons
why somebody who might not
be positively disposed
toward the idea at first
might want to
consider it is when
you think of how
many relationships
are fulfilling in most ways--
again, we're good CEOs together.
We even love each other.
We recognize that the other
person is a good parent.
But we haven't had sex
in, like, 18 months.
Or one of us always wants to
and the other one never does.
And so one person feels guilty.
And one person feels rejected.
This is not rare.
These are not rare situations.
So I'm not saying that
the only sensible solution
for those people is to explore
the possibility of opening up
the marriage, making
it non-monogamous
in some consensual way.
But one of the things that
probably should be on the table
is at least a
conversation about that.
And I don't think it's
serving us well as a society
that all of us are
terrified to broach
that subject with our spouse.
So yes, there are many ways
of trying to fix that problem,
going all-in, love hacking.
But one of them can be
considering non-monogamy.
It is high-risk.
It is especially
high-risk, because we
might think we're going
to be OK with our spouse
having a certain
sort of relationship
with another person.
And then it happens, and we
just feel absolutely eviscerated
by the experience.
And that is the sort of
risk that we're taking.
And it is not to be dismissed.
But just because
there's some risk in it,
doesn't mean we should be
dismissing it out of hand.
Because you know what?
It's not like this monogamous
thing is working for everybody.
LOGAN URY: Great.
So I'm going to ask one
more final question.
And then we'll open it up to
questions from the audience.
This is something that I
ask everyone I interview.
So here it is.
At Google, we have the
google.com homepage,
that white screen with
the logo where people
search billions of times a day.
If you could put a line
of text under the logo,
what would you say?
And since this is a
modern romance talk,
I'll ask, what's
the one line you
would add to
immediately help people
in their sex and relationships?
ELI FINKEL: That was
two things, I think.
OK, so Ellen Berscheid,
she basically
founded a field that
has now called--
maybe tacky-- we call
it relationship science.
It's developing
hypotheses and using data
to test ideas about
what works and what
doesn't work in relationships.
She has a line
that I really love.
And it's something like,
relationships with other humans
are the foundation and the
theme of the human condition.
And so I would put that
underneath the Google bar.
And then I would say, how
are you spending your day?
What was the second question?
LOGAN URY: No, you got it.
ELI FINKEL: Oh, I got both!
LOGAN URY: You nailed it!
ELI FINKEL: Phew, OK.
LOGAN URY: That's perfect.
Whoever here works on
the doodle, get on that.
ELI FINKEL: Yeah, I'm sure
everyone will love that.
LOGAN URY: Great.
So we have Scott and Julia, who
are going to stand up and pass
around the mic.
If you don't mind just standing
up and saying your name,
that would be great.
So raise your hand if
you have a question.
ELI FINKEL: Just throw it.
AUDIENCE: Hi, thanks for coming.
I'm [INAUDIBLE].
In the controlled experiments
that you mentioned
for developing
your love hack, you
said that you asked people to
think about how a third party,
objective person would
interpret the situation.
Why didn't you ask them to
think how their partner would
interpret the situation?
ELI FINKEL: Oh, boy.
That might have
worked too, right?
We based it on research in
social psychology and my home
discipline on the importance
of self-distancing,
on getting away from the
heat of the here and now.
And so the instinct
we had was, what's
an effective means
of getting people
to step outside themselves?
We know that your default
perspective is the one that
comes through your eyes.
And so from your
perspective, it's
easy to focus on what's the
outrages that your partner has
perpetrated.
And we thought,
if you're looking
from an external
perspective, you
may well see things in a more
generous, all-encompassing way.
But your idea of a study, I
think, is fascinating too.
We easily could do a
study-- not easily.
These are hard studies to do.
But we could do a study
where we did our manipulation
and then had another
condition where we said, take
your partner's perspective.
And I have no idea--
it's funny, when you
start thinking, like, I,
myself am a jerk.
How have I been such a jerk?
Because you'd see things
from the other perspective.
I love the idea.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, the
reason I'm mentioning
is I'm always
accusing my husband
of not being empathetic enough.
And I always ask him, why don't
you put yourself in my shoes?
But that doesn't work either.
So I think the good idea is
to bring in a third objective
person.
ELI FINKEL: Maybe
the third party.
So when you're accusing him
of not being sufficiently
empathetic with
your needs, do you
think you're being sufficiently
empathetic with his?
AUDIENCE: Maybe not.
I think I need to bring
in another person.
ELI FINKEL: Right.
From our own perspective, it's
easy to be like, why aren't you
understanding me?
And it's hard to get us out
of that space, especially
when things are feeling tense.
AUDIENCE: Hi, can you hear me?
ELI FINKEL: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I go by
[INAUDIBLE] at Google.
You mentioned that being
educated and having
higher education reduced the
chance of failed marriage.
But I read a research that
professors under tenure track
has one of the highest
rates of getting divorced.
And so isn't it the
case that the level
of your job and the time that
you can have with your spouse
is more of a big factor
into a failed marriage
than the education level?
I mean, that's just one--
ELI FINKEL: No, I mean,
that's a great question.
I don't know the data.
So the data you're
citing suggest
that professors on
the tenure track
are at risk for divorce, which
I mainly just find hilarious.
But the broader
point you're making
is one that's really
important to me.
So I wrote a 2014 op
ed piece in "The Times"
that was also called The
All-or-Nothing Marriage.
It was sort of the foundation
of what became the book.
And Slate published a piece
that seemed really unfair to me.
They published a piece that
the title was something
like, The NYT
Congratulates Rich People
For Having Good Marriages.
And the piece was written.
And it said something
like, what makes
for a marriage good or bad
is not finding time together
or investing in the marriage.
It's about the radical
inequality in our nation.
But the author is right.
And I never said anything
different from that.
You heard me say,
basically, that today.
AUDIENCE: I think you said
two things, which is, like,
education level and
financial stability,
those are the two
co-founding factors.
But then I totally
believe with you
the financial is like one of
the really contributing factor.
But I'm not so sure
about the education
level it was is my point.
ELI FINKEL: Well I
mean, I think we agree.
So what I think anybody who
wants to make that argument--
so if somebody wants to take--
I don't think you do.
But anybody who wants to
take me to the mat and say,
well, it's all
socioeconomic status.
It's all social class.
Because I'm certainly
acknowledging
how important social class is--
needs a compelling explanation
for why millions of rich people
have bad marriages and
millions of poor people
have good marriages.
So I share what I understand
to be your instinct,
is that education
is not destiny,
and that one of the
major reasons why it's
so difficult to achieve a
successful marriage today
in the current socioeconomic
climate for people who are poor
is that there's an immense
amount of stress on them.
And yes, you can get an
immense amount of stress
on you even if
you're well-educated.
You're an investment banker
working 100 hours a week
trying to close a deal.
So these sorts of things are
other sources of big stress.
And do I think that, even
among educated people,
those sources of stress
are likely to put
our marriages at risk?
Yeah, for sure I do.
AUDIENCE: OK.
[INAUDIBLE]
AUDIENCE: Oh, hi.
My name is Ibrahim.
I'm a new grad engineer.
I recently graduated
from school.
So my question is more about
online dating and specifically
these casual dating apps
that people use to meet up.
So in the next few
years, we're going
to have married people who
basically met on these apps.
ELI FINKEL: We
have them already.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, yeah,
just getting more.
So my question is
about, how do you
think that's going to affect
the institution of marriage?
ELI FINKEL: Not
much is my guess.
So the question's about
how marriage is changing
because people met differently.
So online dating-- which is a
term I'm not sure people even
use anymore.
But it was always a misnomer.
Because it's not that
people date online.
They met online.
And now they're meeting through
Tinder, or Bumble or whatever.
And eventually, they
get face-to-face.
And they face the
same sorts of issues
that people who meet through
church or through the baseball
game face.
Do we have rapport?
Is there sexual compatibility,
the sort of stuff
we were talking about earlier.
One of the interesting
questions is,
what are the consequences of
having this massive singles
bar in your pocket
or in your purse?
What are the
consequences of knowing
that there is a
functionally infinite range
of possible people out there
that you could go on a date
with as soon as tonight?
And here, I think I'm one of
the most optimistic people.
And the reason why
I'm less concerned
that having a singles bar
in your pocket is going
is going to break
up your marriage
or any long-term relationship
is because people
who are happy in their
relationship aren't looking.
So it doesn't matter that
there's a huge singles bar.
I think the consequences
of having a big singles
bar in your pocket
or in your purse
are potentially
serious among people
who are becoming dissatisfied
anyway, or at least starting
to feel like, huh, I wonder
what else is out there?
It lowers the friction
between the thought that says,
huh, I wonder what's
out there, and now I'm
actually pursuing something.
Because going out
to a singles bar
and starting to
flirt with someone,
buying someone a drink, or
batting eyelashes, or whatever
people do in singles'
bars, that is
a pretty high bar for
saying, my marriage
is really on the rocks.
Downloading Tinder and swiping a
couple of times is a lower bar.
So I actually think that is
probably the major consequence
that will happen for the
prevalence of these things
for existing relationships.
I think the major consequences
for those people who
are considering
alternatives already,
they're more likely to take
the first step down that road.
LOGAN URY: We have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
OK, that really resonated
with me and great discussion.
Something else that
really resonated
is you're talking about
this idea that a lot of us
want to be entrepreneurs,
but it's scary.
And often, you kind of hope
your partner might support that.
So I have a friend-- and
I don't mean, like, me,
but an actual friend--
who wanted to go and do her PhD.
And her partner was
saying, no, that's
sort of financially
irresponsible at your age.
How might people kind of
resolve something like that?
ELI FINKEL: Is she, like, four?
AUDIENCE: 37.
ELI FINKEL: I don't think
they are one size-- thank you.
I'm grateful to you for
that belated laughter.
Here, again, I mean, look.
What he's saying isn't crazy.
What he's saying would have
been totally reasonable in 1950.
Well, actually, let's ignore
the gender implications.
Because most women didn't get
PhDs in 1950, or most PhDs
weren't awarded
to women in 1950,
or achieved by women in 1950s.
But this idea that
you're supposed
to do what you're
obligated to do, to do
the responsible thing, and
to set aside your hopes
and aspirations is kind of
an older idea, isn't it?
I mean, we could take
a poll of the people
in the room or the
people watching online.
My guess is that most
of us feel like he's
being something of a barbarian,
that it's, like, not really
reasonable to ask her to
forego something that really is
self-expressive for
her, that really is
essential to achieving the
best version of herself,
her ideal version of herself.
And it's cruel,
many of us think,
to make her have a life where
she's going to have regrets
that she didn't
achieve these things.
Is that right or wrong?
I don't know what
to say, other than,
I'm glad we live in this era.
And I'm glad that we have
the defaults toward ambition,
and generosity,
and self-expression
and personal growth
that we have.
And each individual
couple is going
to have to figure out the
circumstances under which they
have to make those
sorts of sacrifices.
And that's the best
I can do with regard
to your particular situation.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
LOGAN URY: So I'm also grateful
that we live in this era
where we can have conversations
like this at work.
And I really want to thank
all of you so much for coming.
For those of you who
have a copy of the book,
Eli's happy to personalize it.
Eli and I also
collaborated on a video,
which we put on Facebook today.
So if you want to check it out,
it's at facebook.com/loganury,
which is U-R-Y. And it's
a three-minute version
of the history of marriage.
So you should check that.
Out you should also
buy Eli's great book,
"The All-or-Nothing Marriage."
And stay tuned for the next
Talks at Google Modern Romance
Talk.
So thank you so much.
ELI FINKEL: Thank you.
LOGAN URY: Thank you.